- I like your shoes.
- Yeah!
They are
three sizes too big but I
wanted them so I got them.
- Oh my gosh I've done
that, I've done that!
I literally got it, it
was a half size bigger
but I was like whatever they're so cute.
- It's fine, I'll grow into them.
- You probably will,
you're so tall and only
16, that's awesome.
- Right thank you, it's a good thing.
- It's so cool. So why
are bows your thing?
They were my thing too
because I was in dance
and all that growing up.
- For sure, that's
actually how they started
for me you know.
When I was little my mom,
I mean I was two years old,
when I was born actually,
my mom just kind of stuck them in my hair,
and my joke is, as I got older,
my bows just kept on getting bigger.
(laughing)
But as I realize that bows are really like
a part of my life,
I realized that I wanted
them to mean something.
And so, what I came up
with is Siwa-nators.
And so if you're wearing a bow,
or you see someone wearing a bow,
that means that they are a Siwa-nator.
So say you're, you know, at school,
or you don't have anyone
to play with at recess,
to sit at lunch with.
- Yeah.
- If you see someone wearing a JoJo Bow,
you know that you can sit with them,
or you know you can play with
them because that person--
- It's a safe place.
- It's a safe place, that
person will be nice to you.
(applauding)
- That's so cool!
- That person will be kind to you.
Yeah! I actually,
if you two are up for it,
I might have a little
present for you guys.
- I am up for it.
(cheering)
Jason!
- I brought you a bright bow
with lots of rhinestones.
- I love that it's yellow too,
because sunflowers are my favorite flower.
- Well there you go.
- Oh my gosh! I'm so into it.
And Jason! I had to bring you a denim bow.
- Hey denim's my favorite color
(applauding)
- I love it!
- You got the back
showing the front, okay.
- My bad.
- There you go!
- I'm just letting you know,
that's a real man that's letting
you touch his cowboy hat.
- Is it? I don't know about that.
- You can sit with me at lunch, it's fine.
- You can sit with me at lunch.